imply that men
you know that men are the ones that only
benefit that's not fair either there's a
lot of women that get into a managed
marriage and they benefit financially
from that situation right
there's a lot of women that have the
opportunity to then say if i want to
have a child that i can stay home if i
want to stay home because you've got a
husband there that's working and paying
the bills that does happen that dynamic
does exist
there's a lot of times that you need a
guy you know what i don't know maybe she
gets on her ladder and she's
fixing everything and she's doing all i
know is that there's a lot of ladies
around there myself included that when
it comes time to hang stuff and fix
stuff and the toilet bowl clogs and this
that i'm very grateful to have a husband
in the house to say babe i don't know
what you did to that toilet i will blame
him oh i will because nine out of 10
times you know it's him that clogged
that toilet up but he's also gonna face
a big babe i'm not gonna get in there
okay when we had when was time to do
stuff with the with the house that
involved anything that i'm not good with
that stuff right he had the drill he had
the you know it